هل يمكنني فقط أن أطلب منك أنك تعلم أن تشرح
ما قلته بنفسك ليس هناك
إجابة أه على هذا التصرف ماذا تقصد
بالضبط بذلك انظر
عندما ننتهي من
هذه المقابلة سيقتل طفل آخر
في غزة في الوقت الذي ستفعل فيه ذلك
سينتهي عرضك، ستقتل
امرأتان أخريان في غزة إلى متى يمكن أن يكون
لإسرائيل هذا الحق الكامل في
الذهاب إلى هذا المخيم الذي قام بحملة لهذه الحرب
ولكن يجب أن تكون هناك حدود وقد
تجاوزناها منذ وقت طويل ولكن قبل كل شيء،
الرد على سؤالك  السؤال هو أين نهدف
إلى ماذا سيكون أفضل
لأمن إسرائيل إذا قُتل 20 ألف
فلسطيني آخر في غزة إذا
فقد نصف مليون شخص
منازلهم، ما الذي يساهم به هذا
في أمن إسرائيل؟ علينا أن
ندرك أن  الأهداف التي أعلنتها إسرائيل
غير قابلة للتحقيق أو على الأقل
غير قابلة للتحقيق جزئيا، وعلينا أن نركز
الآن على خلق واقع جديد وليس
القتل والقتل بغرض
قتل جدعون. أريد أن أتطرق إلى ذلك
في لحظة ولكن للإجابة
وتوضيح ما تريدونه  قلت للتو عن
مقتل المزيد من الأطفال والمزيد من النساء هناك، وهذا هو
الأحدث وعلينا أن نقول مقطع
فيديو مصور قادم من غزة اليوم
أه ناتج عن الغارات الجوية أه
الليلة الماضية مستشفى الأكسا هناك في
غزة يقول أن 57 شخصًا قتلوا وحوالي
70 جريحًا  يقول المستشفى إن ما لا يقل عن 10 من هؤلاء كانوا
أطفالًا،
لذا تستمر الحكومة في القول إنها
تبذل قصارى جهدها لتجنب مقتل المدنيين،
وتواصل الولايات المتحدة القيام بدبلوماسية مكوكية
يبدو أنها تهدف بشكل أساسي إلى
تقليل الوفيات بين المدنيين، ليس هذا فحسب،
بل أيضًا لتقليل فرصة مقتل المدنيين.  إنها
حرب موسعة ولكن في عقلك بعد أن
غطيت الكثير من
حروب إسرائيل وغزة، ما هي النقطة، ما هو
الغرض بعد 3 أشهر من هذا كما تقول،
عدد كبير جدًا من القتلى، ما هي
النقطة الإستراتيجية التي أشك فيها  أشك كثيرا في أن يكون هناك
شخص أولا وقبل كل شيء يدافع عن الأمريكان،
والإسرائيليين، ويبذلون قصارى جهدهم،
ويسأل الأمريكيون بلطف هل
تمتنع إسرائيل عن قتل المدنيين، لكن
النتيجة واضحة جدا، إنها معركة دماء
ودماء.  ولا يمكنك أن تتجاهلها،
فالشخص الوحيد الذي يتجاهلها هو
وسائل الإعلام الإسرائيلية بالمناسبة، إذا سمحت لي أن أدلي
بملاحظة عنها لأن
الإسرائيليين هم الشعب الوحيد في
العالم الآن الذي لا يتعرض على
الإطلاق لما يحدث.  في غزة لا شيء،
كنا نضحك دائمًا على
تغطية التلفزيون الروسي للحرب في أوكرانيا، أما حربنا فهي
أسوأ بكثير لأنه هنا
لا أحد يملي علينا طوعًا عدم
إظهار المعاناة والعقاب في
غزة ولا يتعرض الإسرائيليون لها
ولكن هذا مجرد عرض جانبي.  الطريقة التي لاحظت
بها أن هناك أهدافًا أعلنها رئيس الوزراء
وهي إطلاق
سراح الرهائن وتحطيم حماس بعد ثلاثة
أشهر، أستطيع أن أقول لك أننا لم
نقترب من كليهما، أفكر
في
إطلاق سراح الرهائن R من وجهة
نظري  يجب أن تكون في الأولوية الأولى
وأنهما لا يسيران معًا، وأعتقد أننا هنا
نسير أبعد فأبعد، ونحن
الآن أبعد بكثير مما كنا عليه قبل أسابيع قليلة من
إطلاق سراح الرهائن، وهذا ينبغي أن يكون لدى
أي شخص لديه وعي، هل يمكنني أن أسألك
عن ذلك؟  توسيع الحرب لأن ذلك
أيضًا أمر يثير قلقًا كبيرًا
خاصة بالنسبة للدول المحيطة والولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها أه أساسًا إسرائيل أقوى
الحلفاء كما تعلمون جيدًا ولكني
سأذكر الجميع بما كان
يحدث.  اغتيال
نائب زعيم حماس في بيروت
الأسبوع الماضي مقتل قيادي في حزب الله
في جنوب لبنان أحدهما
ادعت إسرائيل أنه واحد أه ثم
تعلمون أنه كان هناك رد من حزب الله
من حيث استهداف أهداف إسرائيلية مهمة
داخل أه إسرائيل  وآلان بينكاس،
الذي كما تعلمون جيدًا زميلًا
كاتب عمود في صحيفة "هرييت" ولكنه أيضًا
مستشار عام إسرائيلي سابق في نيويورك، كتب
هذا وقال بشكل أساسي إن إسرائيل تبدو
مستسلمة للفكرة، وبعبارة أخرى،
تريد حربًا أكبر كثيرًا لدرجة
أن واشنطن  نقل المقال عن
مسؤولين أمريكيين تعبيرهم عن قلقهم
وتقديرهم أن رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو يشجع التصعيد
كمفتاح لبقائه السياسي وينأى
بنفسه أكثر عن
المسؤولية عن كارثة 7 أكتوبر
أه أم تعلمون أن هذا
أمر مؤلم بشكل لا يصدق بالنسبة
لإسرائيلي حقيقي  مسؤول حكومي سابق
ليقول إن أي دولة تريد
حربًا موسعة، هل تعتقد أن هناك أي
حقيقة في ذلك على الإطلاق،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء، لا يسعني إلا أن أخمن
وأتمنى فقط ألا تكون هناك حقيقة في ذلك،
وأعتقد أن إنفاق هذه الحرب أيضًا
تجاه  الجبهة الشمالية، وتحديداً ضد
الحسبة، ستغير قواعد اللعبة
وستخلق واقعاً
لم يلتقيه الإسرائيليون وإسرائيل قط قبل أن
ندركه. من الجميل جداً أن نتحدث هنا
عن توسيع نطاق الحرب، لكن ما يمكن أن
يحدث بعد ذلك أعتقد أنه أبعد بكثير مما
رأيناه من قبل.  في إسرائيل، في تل أبيب، في
القدس، في أماكن أخرى، استمع،
أنا أعطي نيتان الفضل الأكبر من معظم
زملائي وأصدقائي، لأنني
لا أعتقد أن طموحاته الشخصية
هي الدافع الوحيد الذي
يحفزه، لا أستطيع ذلك  صدقني أنا متأكد من أن
دوافعه الشخصية هي جزء من
اعتباراته وأنا متأكد من أن
خوض هذه الحرب بالنسبة له شخصيًا هو
المنفذ الوحيد قبل الاستقالة الانتخابية
والتحقيق ولكن القول إنه يفعل
كل شيء فقط من أجل الحفاظ على
لا شيء آخر.  يثير اهتمامه أن هذا
أكثر من اللازم بالنسبة إلى نيتان، وأعتقد أنني آمل ألا أكون
مخطئًا، لأنك قضيت الكثير من
حياتك المهنية
في الأساس في مواجهة ما
سأقوله: الذهاب ضد القبيلة ضد
القطيع الذي كنت فيه في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة  كثيرا تتكلم هكذا أه داخل
إسرائيل وأه دوليا في
برامج مثل هذا لا بد أنه
صعب جدا عليك رقم واحد وما هو
رد الفعل على الأخبار التي تعود بها
من الضفة الغربية المحتلة
مثلا صعب لكن صدقني
أن أكون صحفية في غزة الآن هو أمر
أكثر صعوبة بكثير، لذلك
ليس من حقي أن أشتكي الآن عندما
يموت الناس في غزة، أنا لست
المشكلة حقًا، إنها ليست سهلة في هذه الحرب، لقد
أصبحت أكثر صعوبة لأن
بعض أصدقائي المقربين  من أفضل أصدقائي وحتى
أفراد عائلتي غيروا رأيهم في
7 أكتوبر، إنه أمر لا يصدق
ما حدث هنا، أعني أن كل شيء
انهار، كل الفال فال الذي
آمن الناس به انهار فقط بسبب
هذا الهجوم الهمجي الذي كان
هجومًا همجيًا ولكن لا ينبغي أن يتغير  أي
قيم أنا وأنا حقا أصفر في
الظلام لسنوات عديدة أنا معتاد على
ذلك لا أعتقد أن لدي تأثير كبير
ولكني لا أعرف شيئا سوى أن أقول ما
أعتقد أنه حقيقتي وأنا لا  أرى أي
مجال آخر أود أن أكون
نشطًا فيه بدلاً من رواية قصة
الاحتلال لسنوات عديدة
لأولئك الذين لا يريدون أن يسمعوا ولا
يريدون القراءة ولا يريدون أن يعرفوا ولكن
من خلال  وفي نهاية المطاف، فإن الاحتلال
يحدد إسرائيل أكثر من أي شيء آخر،
والحزب الأبرتي يحدد نظام إسرائيل
أكثر من أي شيء آخر، ولا يمكننا
الاستمرار في هذا العمى.
يعيش الإسرائيليون راضين للغاية عن
حياتهم التي عادة ما تكون
جيدة جدًا  ليس في أوقات الحرب بشكل واضح،
وليس لديهم حتى فضول لمعرفة
ما يحدث على بعد نصف ساعة من
منازلنا ونصف ساعة من
منازلنا، حتى قبل هذه الحرب الرهيبة،
هناك واقع غير إنساني يجب أن
ينتهي يومًا ما.  وطالما
أننا سنواصل هذا العمى، فلن
نصل أبدًا إلى أي مكان جيد نحن
الإسرائيليون